okay so then the next last of the day
rather plant plants our in get in
connection and their master sir
Clemens was here I'll explain
well it's not quite like that and I
should say a couple of words first of
all it's very pleased to be invited to
speak here
The Wolf Prize is a prize of which man
mathematics can be proud and it's good
that they wisely added stand to the list
of recipients now actually I can't
resist this recalling a few in a few
words my relations with yield I mean my
relation with Yale were all Oh brief for
exceptionally good I came here first a
long time ago in 1958 I still remember
my arrival I came a little early because
I had a wife when we were bites about to
have a son and I wanted to make sure
that everything was arranged so this she
could come here without too much trouble
so I arrived a few days early in looking
for an apartment but I also was the very
eager to see the department I'd come
from a long way I came from a long way
by train from the west coast of Canada
and I still remember first of all I
wanted to go to lead all over Hall I
came up
Charles Ricker to his professor then if
somebody else were walking over to
George and Harry's that existed then too
and I think it explained what I was who
I wasn't why I was there and it told me
to go home and wait for a few days so I
was at the beginning but those were
actually I wanted I just wanted to say
once I've said it in print once written
in and prints one those two years I was
at Yale only two years they were two
very good years I had a chance of going
to two other graduate schools and one
reason now that I didn't go when I've
always considered myself as very
fortunate to have gone to Yale they were
to basically free year if you go up the
stairs now they meet Oliver Hall was not
connected to Dunham laboratorium but if
you go up the stairs and across the
bridge then on your left is a room and
at that time 58 to 60 that room was
empty there was nothing there there was
a table I think there for maybe four
meetings of the faculty so I that table
all to myself and I spent I would say
every day there
good morning tonight and I read a lot of
books and yay was a good introduction to
a very varied kind of mathematics there
was hillier Hillis book on functional
analysis and semigroups it's a very good
introduction to was a good introduction
to classical analysis probably still is
specially a little plastron form I
remember reading there the first volume
of God I'm getting old
the who's who wrote the book on Fourier
analysis oh boy
no you're younger than I am no the pole
Sigmund I remember reading Sigmund there
for example and Marshall Harvey stones
book on spectral theory and all those
things actually served me in good stead
in later years the second year is that
fortunate enough I was took Kirk Stephen
gall who was a mathematician who came
here after the Hungarian Revolution see
for a brief time but he was interested
in in cell Berg's work partly because he
was a number theorist partly because
Selberg his wife was Hungarian and they
took an interest in him and so I was
introduced to supper by him in the
second year and what else oh yes thanks
to Felix broader and Kakutani who never
got along there was a seminar on
function theory of several complex
variables and thanks to this seminar
that never took place
I read for the first meeting of the
seminar a book on domains of definition
of functions of several complex
variables and those of you who have come
across say the early theory of
Eisenstein theories know that that plays
a role in that theory so they were very
good years and I left and then I came
back again in 68 so 10 years later
stayed only a brief time I stayed for
years which I was absent once and then I
learned a great I started to teach
myself the theory of some more
variety so that was then I had one or
two very good students one of them is
here anyhow
so I was pleased and I could hardly
refuse when I was invited to come here
and speak honor of Dan's 90th birthday
and reception of the Wolf Prize on the
other hand although I've been thinking
for some time about a particular
question and that was if I talked that
was all I could have talked about I
certainly was not ready and I'm not
ready today
and the best but I couldn't refuse so
I'm just going I thought as much as I
could in the few weeks that were
available about what I wanted to do and
whether I could do it and I would like
to like to talk about that with all the
provisional element that it entails so
let me try to try to begin what I was
thinking about as you can imagine if you
two serious aspects of the theory of
automotive forms
let me may I said it before as well but
I'll say it again I just want to remind
you of some of those aspects of the
general theory of auto motoring forms so
what there's the theory also over a
number field and I've tried recently to
by the way there are notes on the web
for this lecture and so I don't feel any
responsibility to say everything that
needs to be said you can grow afterwards
you can even go now if you happen to
have the right kind of do it with you
and read the notes which will be clearer
than I am so if you go to w-w-w point
IAS point math point is point edu and
then you go to publications and then you
go to something called beyond endoscopy
that's the section in these topics you
go to me in the publication's and then
you go to beyond endoscopy you will find
this text which has in the title the
word Mostow and the word lecture so it
shouldn't be not be hard to find and
these are fairly clear and so far as I
can be clear about my topic at the
moment so first of all there's a theory
of of a number field so for that I will
just use language the number field is F
and usually one has a group G like GL n
and the functions on the quotient space
g and g of this is the symbol that
Deline use and we'll I'll explain it
again but any case they're a function on
a space like this as part of the has a
classical theory in it and
so basically the it's not the classical
theory in any in any real sense of the
word but it's the initial theory from so
on which I started and to the theory for
function feels to me for function fields
over over over the theory for function
field over the complexes so for the
field of whole polymorphic functions on
a riemann surface
alright and then the third top so so
these are the three principal topics in
my view and the third topic so this
topic
I want to say I think it's fair to say
and I could say for me but quite frankly
at least if I'm speaking frankly I would
say absolutely and so for me and in
general in general the principal topic
here is punctuality what what is quote
what it's called in this particular area
funky reality it's not a formal funky
reality the funky reality that has to be
proven
now this funky reality is of course
closely read mean contains in particular
class field theory or the curse to me it
didn't occur to me before as I was
preparing this actually the Christian to
me now the words of wisdom I heard here
at Yale about class field theory that
it's something that no intelligent
mathematician learns it's just beyond
the pay is just beyond the pale 19th
from 1959 it was perfectly reasonable
class field theory was focused in
Princeton and I there's not only that
but in 1956 art says more or less
clearly that there is no non-abelian
class because that class field theory
but no none of billion Theory Hartman
says that I knew you would say no but it
if you look at the 1956 Princeton
conference and read what Artin says I
think it's more or less that okay I
don't dispute it but if you are you I
advise you to look for historical
purposes at the 56 Princeton conference
and see what other people say too he may
have thought differently and said
differently at home but any case
it he did say this and this this funky
reality includes it includes so in
particular if you could ever do it
particularly non-abelian at least I
think it does and I'm a billion Class B
appear now I don't think that I know
exactly what to do about proving it but
I think that we now have an idea of what
we have to learn in order to be able to
move to water and the kinds of
experiments that you have to learn the
kinds of calculations we have to make
and so on to reach a stage of maturity
where we can do something about one but
that's not my topic today my topic today
will be two but there's a third topic
and I want to draw to your attention
just briefly so it's the relation
between teen autoboxing forms on the one
hand dear Fantine dear Fantine equations
yeah I just I'm not going to say
anything about it today I can't say
anything about it not something that
I've ever really thought about but so
dear Fantine equations in some sense
that's rather a large topic I mean in
the sense of growing digs notice there
there's apparently a connection we don't
understand it and we don't even know how
to how to grow about understanding it
and but I just suggest that of course
I'm dealing with this problem is
probably tied up with serious advance in
the theory of in algebraic geometry in
the theory of the Oh Fantine equation I
mean in other words Grodin we can't
forget that the growth takes view
implies a particular solution of the
conjecture so you're at least there
right so this two questions seem to be
intimately related means that it's kind
of a surprise that no one is trying to
look at both of them simultaneously all
right but I want to discuss this it's
this - - I don't understand and it's out
there and one way I would like to
understand just what it's all about it's
not so obvious the literature is
fascinating it's a subject that is of
course related to a lot of things it's
related in one way in another to
differential geometry one way in another
to the theory of moduli spaces so it's a
very rich subject and yet it's I find it
very difficult to discover exactly what
it's all about this the thing is the
following thing so I'll explain it
basically if you look at the subject if
you look at the literature what you'll
see is that there's a parametrization
using a parameterization of water
morphing forms
let me speak a little bit loosely by
connections
that seems to be the theory now this
this is a theory that 4gl one is
available and due to vay it's
reproducing the book of Griffiths in
Harris one place I could find it alright
so this is a theory and so this is the
parameterization of autumn autumn forms
by connections now this is perilous
parameterization by connections could be
it's the equivalent is a functor
allottee in the context of it we'll come
back to this but in the content in the
geometric context it's really this this
parameterization by connections or by
the integrals of connections with no
periods that corresponds to punctuality
flunked reality is the following are two
reality one introduces with any group G
1 in this is over F F in this case would
be a number field F in this case would
be a function field of a riemann surface
what when when has G over F then one
introduces a second group G of the same
time this is a reductive group this is
the reductive group over C and what
funked reality as it says in some way or
other what that if wherever we have a
natural home a homomorphism of HL which
is a reductive group over C into GL then
we have corresponding map from Auto
morphic forms or autumn Orphic
representations of H to automotive
representations of G and there's that
there are a lot of technical questions
that come that come up out here for
example questions of ready to endoscopy
and this copy is not a work that most of
you will
hurt I don't suppose but this it's the
fundamental lemma for which to glow was
awarded yes the Fields Medal is a part
of endoscopy so just to give you an idea
it's nonetheless from general point of
view a more technical question do you
remember your response to Rappaport when
he told you what was being talked about
at the seminar that I gave at the corner
mile deep but no no no anyhow
so what I by the way I'm tired so I all
right now but but here's the here's the
thing it's actually a troubling thing
what you read about when you read about
sort of geometric langlands program you
read about something altogether
different namely I would like to
understand it someday but I don't
understand - yeah this deals with the
theory which was introduced these
questions the autumn of reforms in this
form appeared about 1967 I think that
Matt Onan and all of came later and
quite so far as I know independently and
they introduced concepts which involved
G over F over C and G L over C so the
duality between G and G L was between as
far as I can see I've started to study
the relevant literature but haven't
gotten very far there's an entirely
different theory and this is the theory
that
that goes by the name basically it's
this theory to which the word Langlands
program is attached this theory which
which which could which compares forms
of for G and GL but oh it's C so there's
no over a function field I'm there
they're not over guess they're over over
a function field it's it's a it's very
confusing lots of things are confusing
and and one of my next goal is to
understand to understand the Langlands
program in the sense in which I think
it's usually meant for a long time I
didn't realize that I you know you
ordinarily one has the experience
mathematics that things are attributed
to other people that you think are due
to you but it's quite quite different
and I don't know I just look and I don't
know what to say no no no no that's not
clear I you really want to know I don't
know yes maybe maybe I will maybe I'll
take it but I haven't bought it yet I
just would like to know what it's about
I know it's obviously interesting but I
and it's worth worth learning as a but
I'm after a mathematician and not a
physicist this is whether to my agree
grant or not something like that yeah
yeah I said I would like to learn
someday and that's one of my projects
for my old age but I'm not quite ready
it's more complicated than that I think
yeah all right so what I want to do now
is so what happened was that I would
like to understand the the geometric
theory and sort of in the mathematical
sense namely the the functions
so we're from Troy allathee is related I
said I'm tired so I want to be careful
so I wanted
so in the second sense and fix the
mathematical sense but this this is
after all I've said it's a suit but it
does involve a lot of geometry it
involves connections the properties of
connections and involves classifying
space the properties of classifying
spaces and so on and what and I think
there's a real solution I think one can
handle from to reality in this case is
probably considerably easier than in the
arithmetic case but nonetheless it's
very complicated and you can very easily
discover that there are a lot of things
there that you don't quite understand
and I've tried to put them together over
the past weeks it's because I I want to
see can you really prove it it was a do
we know enough to prove it so let me
just remind us I don't know about where
the other speakers have learned but I've
learned but other people's talks go slow
but when I'm talking so fast
all right so let me just say a few
things and let me tell you why I think
in fact we're dealing with something
which is X which is accessible to us now
if we know the right the pertinent
theories and we work hard enough so
anamorphic forms so let me remind you
our functions on G F over so this is a
group like G Ln this is this is a field
it could be a field of rational numbers
but that would be the arithmetic theory
or could it be the field of functions
for Bremond surface and that's our
principal case today and then we have G
a this is the gia Delic so this is
roughly speaking this is something which
this pressure is a restricted direct
product of the local after each each of
these is to feel the power series over
the local field that V so let's do it X
that's this and this obviously embeds in
them and we can do function field case
in any case we can do ramified under AMA
fight it doesn't make any sense at this
stage to do to introduce ramification so
we really want functions which are
invariant under the under the zero
vector that's integral those are
policies the coefficients and oxo power
C now this is on the face of it a
disagreeable object right this is an
infinite dimensional group a and it's
not a it's a difficult situation to
divide by a disagreeable group it's it's
just too big so and all sorts of bad
things that can happen
now you understand right away that all
sorts of bad things that it can happen
and and here's something that I want to
you think that you have to understand
that now I want to confess this that
after these a long time I said you have
to understand why stacks are they're
unnecessary but you do not have to
understand stacks and in fact maybe it's
better off if you don't know stack this
is not such a trivial philosophical
position because there are people I mean
in the 19th century sets pushed out
other things and I think in this century
there's certain kind of funky reality
that's pushing out other things and
those of us who grew up without without
funky reality or attached you know not
so much the number but at least assets
and so we we have to fight back if we
want to fight back so and what seems to
happen is that so you have to think this
is some sort of very complicated
situation you have you're dividing
basically this which which is very very
big algebraic variety by something with
you for you so you have enormous pieces
well one way or another you bring it
down to pieces a reasonable size but
still you know the nature of the group
fixing your point varies from point to
point sometimes very big sometimes it's
very small but it seems to be it's a
kind of miracle basically a miracle the
results in the riemann rule that the
quotient is equity mention everywhere I
mean I don't make a mistake a so the
this quotient which looks so bad is
equity really isn't more or less the
same everywhere I don't I haven't got so
far as to thinking about singularities
equi dimensional and even even finite
dimensional although it has an infinite
perhaps an infinite number of components
so it isn't so pleasant you have to
think about it
finite dimensional but but big and the
thing is if you're in algebraic geometry
don't really like things to be so big R
this might really would prefer that they
would be finite dimensional e be
complete and that would be it but it's
not the case now if you're if you're an
analyst on the other hand if you're an
analyst for you basically the theory I'm
gay I just maybe maybe not I'm sure this
wouldn't have been the case for all
fours but any for someone who sort of
grown up in the time that I grew up and
studied have agenda and it's automotive
forms of representations are really
functions on this space right and I say
this finite dimensional space but very
big so and the you need so and the
theory consists of two things it
consists so and I want to say this in
other words one knows from one's
experience with the Siri of Fourier
series that there's a usual theory of
Fourier series there is the Laplace
transform
there is Paley Wiener theorems there
Schwarz hmm but so maybe you know so we
could test people and we can see what
the two color or the two colors I'll be
asking which of those they prefer now
and I think I like the one that's due to
furry namely basically the theory of the
l2 theory and the others are adjuncts
the Paley Wiener theorem you may or may
not want to learn applies times when you
may may not want to learn Schwartz
theory may be a
the distributions there maybe something
but well what I wanted to say as I said
I'm not I like this and so I would
prefer that everything be expressible in
l2 sense I think the basic reason is
that for El tool is really a notion of
completeness for distributions you never
know quite when to start
a lot of the eigen distance for Fourier
transform before you see for every eigen
right there's a unique eigenfunction or
maybe just several so we there is a
notion of completeness which is just a
theory of completeness of view of the
eigenvectors of a hermitian operator so
it's quite standard classically and i'm
the other see the complete this
advantage I guess depends upon your
choice so we really need to make sense
of this all right so I think it's fair
enough when you read the literature
first of all the a that it's a it's a
manifold complex manifold and I'm not
sure if I'm not sure this this space let
me divide let me assume there's no
ramification and divided by G all the
ways of a so do not the full thing but
did you always so that let me put it
that and we need a complex manifold and
needs to be a Kahler manifold now I was
been reading a paper of a TN bog I'm
exactly this kind of question I must
confess I find a very charming paper I
I'm curious I don't know if anyone has
know whence the charm come from the tea
or from Bob but it's not a question I
can answer
but and I think that so this I mean and
part of the fascination is of course
that this links everything up with
hamilton-jacobi theory
hamilton-jacobi theory so it expressed
it to some extent that the depth of the
geometric depth all right so if you
accept my reading of the apart that it
looks as though that we're using
hamilton-jacobi theory one can make this
into a complex manifold with the
tailoring structure then we're pretty
far along there
the central difficulty is what seems to
me the not the sent at the central
difficulty but one difficulty is the
hacker hacker operator the theory
revolves around the specters these are
the operators whose spectral theory is
to be examined and understood now if you
look I mean if you if you look and what
is you so I don't know I mean then fell
this the name that comes up mind first
of all when one thinks of the geometric
theory and theory of the heck are all
operators but the theory but the heck of
operators are really defined in some
sense by sheeps as they appear in so
there is a problem there is a problem
and getting a hold of the operators that
define the spectral theory now as far as
I can see without any work through it
they put the I thought I wouldn't have
too much connection with the other talks
but the some appropriate words were
notions were evoked in the other talks I
mean I this business of getting from
ecology or homology to integrals
it's what gauss-bonnet does and is what
rescue McPherson do in a certain sense
also so I think it's a mountable I'm not
sure I really I've thought about it but
the difficulty is as I say when you take
this quotient everything is chopped up
into so you have well what's the word
that the they using dirt with Goreski
McPherson they have these various pieces
and so on you know yeah
trafficking you have this terrible
stratification and and you have to work
with it but if that's necessary then you
can presumably get by this in the
initial stage and then you have a
spectral theory to examine you just have
to show that you have the complete set
of eigenvalues and so on now let's just
gone a little further so so it what
begins to look more like an analytic
problem although it's a little bit more
complicated in me than usual analytic
problem but none of us that's what it
seems to be now but then there's another
thing so another central point which
confuses the innocent reader and
confuses perhaps the not so innocent
reader it's the theory in which one has
so to speak how do I put it put it so
there's there's an analytic theory the
analytic theory
so it's let me say this there's there's
a difference between say an elliptic
function even a hole of morphic elliptic
function a hole above a elliptic
function is that the form e to the Daisy
and it's and so there there's this
function but as e to the AZ over e to
the of the absolute value B to the AZ
and absolute value of e to the AZ and in
an eigenfunction problem it's these that
occur absolutely i mean we take the cart
we take the Exponential's are absolute
value one if you want to get a periodic
function on it on left under
elliptic curves you better take
something like this not something like
this huh so and as I said if you look if
you look at this at vase they looked at
there's no direct reference to VAE that
I have but he looked at this problem for
gr1 so he dealt class characters and for
he described the Dale class characters
but Dell class characters are things
like that and but implicitly is always
around this so and and and what I
discover on reading the literature is
that no one carefully I would say no one
I think it's bare enough I the the serie
the series the general series say for
connections I can find in say in
Simpsons papers probably in other papers
as well
theory of harmonic mapping said I don't
fully understand but if you look for
example someone from whom I've learned a
lot but who's quite casual about this is
that is that he does not distinguish
between this and this hmm I he doesn't
ever mention them but but his it in say
in basically in Franco's expositions the
eigenfunctions of the hep hecka operator
are those but it's also perfectly
reasonable and in the elf true theory
that I propose it would be perfectly
reasonable to take to look for something
like this
after all this and the quotes are
intimately linked you can't get one
without getting the other and it's it's
very peculiar that and and this is the
differences I think the language is the
words that's involved is what is it I
think
yeah this distinction is between flat
bundles in the literature and harmonic
bundles so this corresponds to the
holomorphic theory and this corresponds
to the other kind of theory and and
Simpson for example in his report that
the Kyoto is very clear about the
distinction and the equivalents between
them and so on so it's not it's not
something that appears here for the
first time and and one is is is a theory
which is approachable by with an L true
theory with this with this with this
spectral analysis the other is not and
if you look and the other is the first
one namely this one is one in which is
quite easy to speak not natural to speak
of the eigen values eigen functions of
hecka operator simultaneous
eigenfunctions whereas this one is not
and if you look III described it here
but if you look for example and I think
it probably is taken from drinfeld was
probably hard to find but if you look at
Franco's description of an eigen
function of the heck operator you will
wonder for some time as you stupid as I
am maybe not so we're short a time to
yourselves what he's doing all that for
and he's doing all that because he
doesn't if you only work with sheeps
you can't introduce these things so so
something has to be done I think it can
be done and then then where do you go
then where do you go you see if we have
so we're looking at now this is a big
space but I say if you start to look at
this big space this could this quotient
space and think about the functions
you'll see that a large number of there
by Eisenstein series and I just and
series are not treated always with
respect so they can be thrown away and
that's usually done in what you're left
with a much smaller set so it isn't that
it's all that it isn't that there aren't
advantages to be gained in going to
smaller sets but basically if you're
looking for everything you look for
everything
least everything which is relevant for
the l2 theory and then they say then you
get eigen function you get argued
functions in in the l2 sense and the
functional in that analytic sense get
eigen functions and and the theory is
well as these hecka operator understood
going to see what the eigen functions
are and you really understand the
unitary eigenfunction so but these
eigenfunctions are parameterize the
point is that they're paralyzed by
conjugacy classes
in this in this group even by semi
simple conjugation classes so and I
require you if you haven't thought
everything about Hagen riser heckle
operators you you haven't but the thing
is that these heck orbit is such that
there's one there's sort of speak one
part attached to each point so you have
the you have the X X is the riemann
surface and to each point you have a
conjugacy class so you need to have
continuous families of operators so
there's like one moment algebra I once
was take a reading a book about I know I
know I'm an algebra I don't know so you
have so an eigenfunction the heck
operator is the conjugacy class or so to
each point x in buck and bungee you have
a conjugacy class in the group that
means you have a basically if you went
with any luck you'll have a conjugacy
class in the algebraic group hmm so you
have the conjugacy class in the group
you know group and and then you get so I
mean if you have one at every point then
you get immunised by something out to
break you guess you get one that's must
be more or less as a theory that's
available from that standard theory of
algebraic groups so what we get sort of
automatically in the in the unitary
situation in the l2 situation is we get
the parameter that we're looking for but
it's not so automatic but you can see
that how it goes you you have a
conjugacy class at each point so this is
a function and then sort by standard
theories of car town algebra so elements
you have you have something so the
passage the passage from the l2 theory
to the connection should be pretty much
an exercise I don't know so as I said
funk reality would be for in the
algebraic in the function field case
would be to say every other more thing
the automotive forms that eigenvalue the
heck operators are parametrized by
connections all right I've been a little
bit careful about integral I'm really
working with integrals of connections
and I really have to choose the
integrals over a single value but so so
that's one direction and then you you
have to go the other direction you have
to go from a connection you see if one
understand Simpson and so on is having a
unitary connection in this sense gives
me a whole amorphic connection and then
hmm and so I should be able to go this
connection gives me a whole amorphic
connection and some or other I get I
have to get back to the eigenfunction I
think it's won't be so hard
I don't really really know yet forgive
me I was doing things in a rush so that
is somehow if you like it's a vision or
an illusion of the way the functionality
might function in the geometric case and
it's I think if we could do it this way
if one could do it this way it would be
a lot clearer than some of the circum
illusions that are invoked there's no
proof oh by the way Lester's in the in
in in Sirte peek in the sheath theoretic
form that's explained and advocated in
large number of places there's a promise
of a proof but it's yet there's no proof
so I don't know exactly what the
situation is but here I have the feeling
that I can see more or less how to work
the ones way to the proper existence in
an existence there which would then
accommodate whatever the the sheep here
is she theories I've thought of what's
the natural word for sheep theorists in
English I thought I post myself to
question the word that comes to mind as
fascist of course but any any I would
like to see that and I would like to see
it yeah the geometric theory and so to
speak I struggled for the past few weeks
just to clarify my thoughts I didn't
make them very clear but that's the best
I can do
thank you
is like a natural language well what I
was saying at the beginning is I think
that the idea of font reality in the
geometric theory is something different
than the the idea is advocated by
Montone and Godard
so and I I don't think they they haven't
i've looked at this i've read some of
these papers with all they care i could
give and and i don't think they're
necessarily useful i what is it what is
useful and important it seems to me is
that the construction of the classifying
space is hard it has to be given some
thought because these groups are so big
and because nature of the fixture of the
stabiliser of a point very so markedly
people in one place to another but i
know i don't want to give one can see
and when seen in modern day mathematics
this pressure which must be analogous to
the pressure to do to you sets now i'm
happy to use sets chroniker wasn't happy
to use that but I'm happy to use that so
I really can't say to someone else I I'm
happier with the function than with a
sheep it is the case so so my purpose is
do is to make think functions they're
very clear and and smoother but whether
that's ultimately the case is hard to
say ultimately the case you know why we
all speak English not because it's a
better prettier or more elegant language
than various other languages because
everyone else does it so it's it will be
the same person
which function feels over fine that you
okay
but they but for function fields that
were fine I feels this this distinction
for example between Chiefs and functions
it's not so great what but but the
theory is different too then I I don't
know if I mention it but use you one
feature of the function field appears to
be that Rama Newton's conjecture is
strictly true yeah the trivial
automotive form does not satisfy so it
appears to be that that the spectrum is
entirely tempered right there wasn't it
was over function field of a finite
field of a number field the spectrum is
not purely tempered and is there's a
bloody nuisance but but here I I haven't
really proved it but I I think it's not
such a hard theorem so I don't know so I
mean well nobody but this thing this
this Grodin deccan distinction mean
state a statement that the number of
that the Chiefs are functions it's a
state something over finite fields all
right and that makes a big difference
I didn't say it because I said I think
that what a TMT I bought do this did
they show basically what they say show
in their paper is that if one sort of
because they're only interested in the
good part of it of the classifying space
right so what a stable vector bundles
and so on and then what basically they
show is that with the introduction of a
little bit of hamilton-jacobi theory you
get a cool area manifold all right so
it's a question of extending that to I
mean maybe they have it someplace else
but for me at the moment it's just a
question of taking that remark and
understanding it and making sure that it
does in fact extend to the whole moduli
space oh no it doesn't have measures it
carries the Eisenstein series really I
mean if you take the moat I mean one of
the simplest cases is the case that the
rebound services of genus 0 and they're
classifying space is discrete and some
some part most of it I guess this
belongs to do things that I'm not but
what's the phrase for stable they're not
stable ok so no you don't lose them
there they're like they're a bit like
the cusps in the in in the number field
case I don't I realized this morning
that I have a confused view of them
they're not like pieces sticking out
they're like little hairs here and there
but I I haven't started to they should I
say they carry the Eisenstein series so
over over field of genus zero there
everything